Hallo Leute, auch mal kürzer am Start hier.
So, mal warten bis Twitch die Ankündigung verschickt hat, Ankündigung ist raus.
Soll ich euch mal das neueste erzählen?
Ich bin um 5 Ecken in Verhandlung für bisschen mehr Sellout.
Ich glaube es ist noch keiner da, oder?
Ihr habt ja sicherlich nix gegen ein bisschen Overlay im Stream oder ab und zu mal im Video.
Was halten die eigentlich von der Idee, wenn ich die Twitch Emotes, die sind ja nicht Twitch
exklusiv?
Soweit ich weiß, ähm, bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher.
Can I use my Twitch Emotes on YouTube?
Das wird mich echt mal interessieren.
Ich würde sagen, kann ich?
So wirklich sicher bin ich mir da nicht, weil ich habe mir nämlich überlegt, ob ich das
auf YouTube nicht so mache, dass ich Wuppock und sowas als Channel, wie heißt es, ich habe
vergessen wie es bei YouTube heißt, Channel, Channel, Mitgliedschaft, Member, Gedöns mache.
Da gibt es bei YouTube noch ein bisschen Stonks.
Use same Emotes on Twitch and YouTube.
Ja, aber ich wollte euch was anderes zeigen.
Twitch hat es aber glaube ich nicht richtig gecheckt, dass ich Stream Champ, ja, ich zeige,
ich verrate euch jetzt nämlich gleich noch was.
Tja, okay, keine Ahnung, weil ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich wie gesagt das als YouTube
Channel Membership mache.
Den aus ist raus.
Ja Leute, die alte Beta-Preis-Champ-Seite gibt es nicht mehr.
Es gibt jetzt den neuen Preis-Champ.
Guckt es euch mal an, bam.
Der neue Preis-Champ ist am Start, neuer IP, 10 Ausgangs-IPs, 10 Ausgangs-IPs, neuer Surfer
und ein paar neue Features, guckt mal, seht ihr das da oben, Leute, guckt mal, guckt mal
da oben, seht ihr das?
Der Dark Mode haben wir schon die ganze Zeit, aber seht ihr die Search, da kann man zum
Beispiel eingeben Nvidia und dann filtert er nur Grafikkarten, also nur Nvidia-Grafikkarten
oder man gibt ein AMD, dann findet er die AMD Ryzen CPUs und die Grafikkarte oder man
gibt RX ein oder man gibt Otto ein, geht auch, ist das nicht nice?
Und auch voll responsive, seht ihr das hier?
So, es ist aber glaube ich so das einzige neue Feature, was es gibt, denn die Alarmgeschichte
kennt ihr ja schon, die passe ich noch ein bisschen an, die ist auch nicht schön implementiert.
Dann, also Leute, ich baue noch eine Sache ein, ich baue noch eine Sache ein, bevor das
ganze live, live geht, wenn du den R eingibst, werden X-Boxes angezeigt, ja, weil das Serious
X ist, Serious, das heißt ja nicht, dass es damit beginnen muss, also wenn du nämlich
Serious, oh, Serious eingibst, dann siehst du, dass das included, ja, Relax, 14 Monate,
Dankeschön für den Sub, 3 Monate und 14 Monate Sub, exquisite, nice subscriptions, du kannst
die Grafikkarten nach Hersteller filtern, du gibst einfach Nvidia ein und dann hast du
nur Nvidia Zeug, oder du gibst keine Ahnung, AMD ein, ok, dann kriegst du noch die CPUs
dabei, aber das wird man erstmal verkraften, ne, mit Autos geht es glaube ich nicht, da
gibt es nichts zum Crawlen, so, und ich hab mir was überlegt Leute, nachdem das Ding
jetzt so, was, für das Custom Chip, what, das ist zu big brain chat, verstehe euch nicht,
nicht für das Custom, hast du Erfahrung mit LED-Panelen an der Decke, ne, warum hast du
nicht als Top Level Domain Punkt POG genommen, gibt es das, gibt es Punkt POG Domain, POG,
ne, Punkt POG gibt es nicht, ach so, das geht nicht richtig, das geht nicht richtig,
ich hab die Info zwar, was es für einen Hersteller ist, aber das Fuzz wollte ich eigentlich jetzt
nicht aufmachen, weil sobald du mit Herstellern anfängst, dann musst du theoretisch den ganzen
Kram noch nach Herstellerfiltern und sowas, dann gilt ja auch das nicht mehr, weil das
ist der Durchschnittspreis über alle am Tag, und dann müsstest du das nach Typ anzeigen,
ok, was man machen könnte ist, einfach alles so lassen wie es ist, das schreibe ich mir
mal auf, man könnte alles so lassen wie es ist, aber man könnte hier irgendwo dahinter
schreiben welche Sort es ist, aber was ich nicht einbauen kann ist, dass man Notifications
nur nach Grafikkarten typen machen kann, oder so, das ist zu kompliziert, das macht es
dann auch, ne die können nichts tolles, ich schreibe mir mal das kurz auf, also was ich
machen kann ist, ich kann hier dahinter schreiben, was es für einen Hersteller ist, hier unten
oder so, dann schreibe ich Notebooks billiger ist der Shop, und dann schreibe ich hier unten
drunter keine Ahnung, MSI oder ASUS oder so, das weiß ich, an der Stelle das kann ich
machen, aber alles andere ist ein bisschen zu kompliziert, so, und das kann man dann
auch filterbar machen, ja das funktioniert, das könnte ich machen, ja, so und wie gesagt
Filtern, ich meine Filtern, ganz ehrlich so kompliziert wäre Filter nach Hersteller an
der Stelle gar nicht, da wird es hier unten einfach einen Dropdown geben, ob man noch
nach Hersteller filtern will oder nicht, aber ansonsten würde ich die Anzeige gar nicht
großartig erweitern, ne,.org ist doch top,.org klingt vertrauenswürdig, also ich weiß
nur den Hersteller, ich weiß nur den Hersteller, ich weiß theoretisch auch noch das Brand,
da steht dann sowas drin wie AMD Reference oder so, aber das wird zu abgedreht, ne die
.de Seite ist irgendwie so ein Crap, also den genauen Typ der Grafikkarte weiß ich nicht,
ich weiß nur noch, das ist welcher Hersteller, das weiß ich und ich weiß so ganz grob was
es für ein Model ist, aber da würde ich mich jetzt nicht drauf verlassen, hast du mal
die Statistik von der Webseite gezeigt, ne, aber es sind so ungefähr 1000 bis 2000 Leute
am Tag aktuell, obwohl ich es noch nirgendswo gezeigt habe, ja, die Domain zeigt auf Cloudflare,
korrekt, ja, das ist Absicht und das obwohl ich es noch nirgendswo vorgestellt habe, so
Leute, dedost ihr schon, seid ihr schon am Hexhorn, ja, alles schon da, by the way ich
hab es jetzt auch so gemacht, wenn ich IP leake ist es überhaupt kein Ding, ich kann
einfach easy innerhalb von 5 Minuten aus dem Snapshot restoren, so, gucken wir mal die
Containerauslastung an, Boring Euklid, Alter, ok, die ist gut beschäftigt die Kiste, ist
es ein Champ, das weiß, ja, die E, die E, Container sind ganz gut am Auslass, also Leute
ihr müsst ja mal drauf ein bisschen Action machen, kann ja nicht sein, dass der Preischamp
selber bei 7% CPU-Last rumguckt, gebt mal alles, er, also aktuell sind das, wenn es interessiert,
16 CPU-Kerne, hat er bis hier was zu tun, das Ding, und eins muss man ja mal sagen, die
Statistiken sind richtig poggers, guckt euch das mal an, da kann man nämlich richtig,
übrigens die UVP-Preise wurde ich heute drauf hingewiesen, stimmen nicht mehr, aber wisst
ihr was, die können mich mal, die sind jetzt 20 Euro teurer, aber ich hab keinen Bock,
jedes mal, wenn die was am UVP machen, ist UVP da drin auch anzupassen, das bleibt jetzt
auf 700 Euro und gut ist, ja, aber guckt euch mal die Preise an, das ist nicht normal, übrigens
das ist auch neu, man kann theoretisch umschalten, das geht aber gerade noch nicht, sag ich euch,
man kann umschalten zwischen einer Woche, einem Monat und komplett, kann man die Symbole zuordnen,
was was ist, würdet ihr das verstehen, dass das eine Woche ist, das ein Monat ist und das
komplett, warum sollte man nicht jedes mal, wenn du Cloudflare hast, ich will ja wissen, ob das alles
funktioniert, vor allem interessiert mich gar nicht so sehr, ob Cloudflare auch wirklich das
alles abfängt, sondern wie viel User ich auskomme, weil wenn ich das am Wochenende wirklich auf
YouTube zeige, dann hab ich auf einen Schlag erstmal, keine Ahnung, 10.000 User oder so,
das mit dem Haken nicht, Monat auch nicht wirklich, das ist das offizielle Symbol für Monat,
Alter, das verstehe er, ich habs auch nicht verstanden, ich habs auch nicht verstanden,
ich habs jetzt auch nicht verstanden, bei dir lehts nicht mehr, das liegt an dir,
funktioniert alles noch, bring es hier für die Notifications, mach ich unten einfach einen Knopf
rein, ansonsten checkt das keiner, aber man muss schon sagen, die Statistiken sind echt nice,
oder? Vor allem, dass man das jetzt auch maximieren kann, kannst du genauer zugucken,
das ist okay, hier war es mal sogar billiger als das UVP, ich glaub, das haben wir gefaked,
das UVP und dann hier ist es jetzt aktuell irgendwie das 100€ mehr, das Fronten ist komplett
selbst gebastelt, ja, der Carlton, 16 Monate Dankeschön für den Sub, Massive, was für Cores sind das
denn eigentlich, das ist eine gute Frage, ich guck mal nach, ob man das sieht, Cut, Proc, CPU,
Info, AMD, Epic sind das, Epic AMDs, okay jetzt sind ein paar, oh nice, nee, Chat, das hätte ich jetzt
aber besser von euch erwartet, da geht mehr, da geht mehr, ich glaube ja, das Frontend ist
relativ performant, weil ganz ehrlich, der Server muss nichts machen, der Server liefert euch eine
Webseite aus und kriegt dann ein paar CraftQL Websocket Anfragen, also, ah guck mal hier,
jetzt sind die russischen DDoSer am Start, jetzt geht es ab, oh nice, excellent, excellent,
aber da sehe ich immer noch nix, sorry, falls ich irgendwelche Subs überszenen habe, ich guck
gerade nochmal, nee, Omo das funktioniert nicht, Hetzner DDoS Filter, kann es vollknicken, wie
kommuniziert das Frontend mit Street Merchant, das ist eine gute Frage, der Cloudflare ist
komplett free, ja, ist es, ja, ich kenne die Emotes von ihm nicht, es sieht irgendwie ein
bisschen aus wie er, so, also Cloudflare ist komplett free, bei Cloudflare bezahlst du Bonus
Sachen, wo war jetzt die Frage, wie das, also, wie kommuniziert, gar nicht, gar nicht, gar nicht,
das Frontend kommuniziert nicht mit Street Merchant, der Crawler ist Street Merchant mit
ein bisschen Custom Patch, was ganz kleines, dass das besser funktioniert, aber, also, ich
kann es dir aber erklären, wie das funktioniert, wie gesagt, der kommuniziert nicht direkt mit
Street Merchant, was das macht ist, das ist einmal ein Vue.js Frontend und es ist ein ASP.NET Core.NET
Backend und dieses Backend hat eine SQLite Datenbank und da steht eigentlich alles drin,
also, wenn ihr auf die Webseite geht, macht er ziemlich zügig gehende SQLite Queries,
was ganz gut funktioniert, weil es ist nicht schreiben, es ist nur lesen und SQLite lesen,
verschiedene Zugriffe ist vollkommen in Ordnung, geht zackig, also, da muss ich nicht mal irgendwie
eine Postgres oder eine MySQL oder irgendwas hinstellen und wie der die Info vom Street Merchant
bekommt, ist eigentlich ganz einfach, Street Merchant kann auf MQTT einliefern, das ist so
ein Lightweight Message Protokoll und ich habe einfach einen.NET MQTT Server laufen in meiner
ASP.NET Anwendung, also, hier, das da habe ich am Start, also sprich, in meiner Web Anwendung
läuft so ein MQTT-NET Server und der kriegt einfach die Dinger eingeliefert, Proxidee,
Dankeschön für den Sub, oh stimmt, wir müssen Dark Mode, Alter, wo ist denn, wo ist, habe ich
da keinen Dark-Reader, mein deutscher Profil, wo ist mein Dark-Reader, ah ja, ich habe den
falschen Broser am Start, exquisite, genau, und das Ding habe ich in meiner ASP.NET Anwendung
laufen und da liefert das Street Merchant ein, das heißt, die einzige Verbindung zwischen,
also es gibt zwischen dem Web Frontend und dem Street Merchant keinerlei Verbindung und
auch zwischen dem Street Merchant und der ASP.NET Anwendung ist es einseitig, der Street Merchant
liefert ein und das ASP.NET schreibt es in der SQLite Datenbank und wenn dann einer queried,
dann kriegt er das halt zurück, wird bei jedem Request neu aus der Asse, das ist teilweise
gecached, wenn es die gleichen Sachen sind, ist es gecached, das macht EF Core selbst,
aber die Anfragen sind so schnell, das wird auch gut funktionieren ohne Cache, weil der
Kram ist auf einer SSD und ich glaube so ein Query dauert, 20 Millisekunden oder so, du
kannst dir das russische Botnetz nicht mal leisten, oh, feelsBatman, ich glaube, DDoS'n
klingt eh nix mehr mit Cloudflare, mich würde einfach nur mal interessieren, wie viel legit
User das Ding ab kann, ach ja, und was ist den CPU-Spike, den ihr da im Hintergrund seht,
nein, oh ja, das muss ich noch fertig machen, bevor ich das release, die PWA, die PWA muss
unbedingt noch gemacht werden, ja richtig, das habe ich ja oft geschrieben schon, aber
ich habe es noch nie, die PWA, ich meine, du kannst zwar ausbrennen, aber ich glaube
ich, dass die PWA schon geht, erstmal die Preis-Champ-Daten per Prometheus-Exporter
rausgeben, da ist kein Prometheus-Exporter, oder Hättest, oder Meinst du, oder Yoshi,
also du hättest die Daten gerne als Prometheus-Exporter, yes, also ich habe da nen Prometheus drauf
auf dem Server, aber der macht Linux-Gedöns, genau, also die Auslastung, so und das was
ihr da ab und zu mal als CPU-Spike seht, ist die Craft-Generierung, weil ich will ja nicht
jedes Mal den Craft berechnen, wenn einer so nen Craft anfragt, das heißt ich mache
alle 10 Sekunden im Hintergrund ne Craft-Aktualisierung und ich behalte das auch im RAM, weil das
braucht nicht viel, echt, wird einem ne PWA vorgeschlagen, ich würde mich jetzt echt
wundern, ich habe nämlich den ganzen Kram gelöscht, oh, ich hab Notifications an, oh
guck mal, Chrome macht jetzt auf einmal Geräusche, hat es die ganze Zeit net gemacht, ne, da kannst
du keine PWA installieren, das mach ich noch, das mach ich noch bevor ich das raushaue,
ja, ja, äh, Topics, hat man verstanden wie es funktioniert, äh, maybe make, nee, maybe
make, zwei Monate lang schon für den Sub, exquisite subscriptions, naja, weil es mich
interessiert kann ich das und so richtig viel mit klassischem Server-Admin-System-Integration
hab ich ja auch net mehr zu tun, ich würde aber auf der Arbeit gern mehr programmieren,
du musst ein, also mich würde viel weniger, ähm, das jetzt probieren Cloudflare zu de-dossen,
sondern gucken, ob wir die Web-Anwendung wirklich voll kriegen, also mich würde halt echt interessieren,
wie viel User die ab kann bevor ich die auf YouTube loslasse, ne, ja nice, nice, dass du
lange am Start bist, ähm, wie gesagt heute bin ich nur kurz on, ich hab eigentlich gedacht
ihr könnt einfach mal alle auf den, auf den Preisschamp gehen, also wer jetzt noch nicht
drauf ist, lass mal auf, lass mal ausbilden, gehn doch mal alle auf beta.preisschamp.org
und bleibt einfach mal auf der Seite drauf, und dann will ich mal die Auslastung gucken,
mein Problem ist, äh, ich kann jetzt grad nicht wirklich die User zählen, weil dazu
hab ich das Passwort nicht, kannst doch mit 100 neuen Scroms gleichzeitig die Seite, ja
mach ich, was wird das, wenn's fertig ist, ein Preissracker, das funktioniert doch schon
ganz gut, so, ich mach, Leute, ich mach die jetzt selbst ein paar mal auf, so, der Preisschamp
wird gespammt, exquisite Preisschamping, Preisschamping, jetzt wär noch was neues, so, ich glaub'
jetzt ist glaub' ich meine, meine VM bald mit dem RAM am Ende, das funktioniert ohne
jegliche Probleme, juckt den auch nicht, ok, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt sind wir ein paar drauf,
jetzt gibt's mir ein bisschen Last, wir dürfen nicht vergessen, diese Anzeige hier ist,
ähm, diese kurzen Spikes ist das, äh, Dings generieren, das macht nix, ähm, wir dürfen
nicht vergessen, 100, es ist 100% von einem CPU Core, also das sind aktuell 60% von einem
CPU Core und das Ding hat 16, ob das neueste oder das billigste, du kannst einfach drauf
klicken, hast du das schon gesehen, wenn du draufklickst, siehst du immer das billigste
zuerst, aber du meinst in der Übersicht, ne, das ist, das ist das Ctop von GitHub,
das ist nicht das eingebaute Ctop, oder Jensho, du meinst, dass du das auf der Übersicht
siehst, weil wenn du's nach Preissortiert haben willst, kannst du einfach draufklicken,
äh, da muss ich jetzt mal fragen Jensho, hast du das vorher schon gesehen, dass das
geht, weil ich bin mir immer noch nicht sicher, ob die Leute checken, dass man hier draufklicken
kann, oh, das ist ein Bug, das hat nix, ah, tatsächlich, oh, lull, ok, gut, ja, na, kann
ja mal passieren, lull, alles klar, ich weiß auch, woran das liegt, das ist aber gut, dass
wir das hier zusammen ausprobieren, da, so ein Bescheid, auf mobile Ansicht die Lupe
ein bisschen hinter der Überschrift, ok, hab ich mir noch nicht angeguckt aufm, ich
guck mal kurz auf meinem, äh, iPhone, wie's da aussieht, ja, das sind so kleine Sachen,
das muss man mit der Zeit, mit der Zeit fixen, deswegen ist es ja auch die Beta-Preis-Champ,
oh stimmt, auf mobile, auf mobile ist es ziemlich kaputt mit der Suche, auf, auf mobile hängt
bei mir die Lupe in der Überschrift drin, das sackt natürlich so ein bisschen, und
die Suche scrollt bei mir mit auf mobile, ok, das ist auf jeden Fall so nicht gedacht,
da muss ich noch mal ran, plot twist die Anwendung Single Core, nee, also, auch wenn's als Witz
gemeint ist, aber gerade Anwendung mit Webrequest sind ja so geil zu parallelisieren da, also
schauen wir mal, wie gesagt, CPU ist das hier, das ist ein, ein AMD Epic, tja, mehr sieht
man da nicht, das hat Hexner wahrscheinlich überschrieben bei KVM, oder habt ihr eine
glorreiche Idee zu erkennen, was das hier für einer sein könnte, Prozessor 15, CPU Family
23, tja, 15 ist halt die Anzahl, 2,5 GHz, tja, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das für einer
genau ist, aber auf jeden Fall was ordentliches, das stimmt, das zeigt immer, das zeigt immer
das letzte an, ich überleg's mal, ob ich ne Option einbaue, die Sache ist aber die,
ich wollt das eigentlich so lassen, weil ich hab schon mitgekriegt, dass viele Leute stehen
ultra auf diesen Glücksspiel Faktor, die gucken dann, ich seh das ja in den Statistiken
teilweise, die gucken dann 10 Minuten auf die Seite drauf, um das beste zu erwischen,
ist das Notify-Icon extra hell, das Notify-Icon extra dunkel, ja, das Notify-Icon ist hell
und Disabled, sobald du's anschaltest, ist es auch dunkel, das ist Absicht, mal eine
Frage an alle, habt ihr eine Idee, wie man seine Nutt-Typen besser machen kann, ja, also
du musst dich erstmal, wo ist das, Nutt, also, meine Frage an alle, habt ihr eine Idee,
wie man seinen Nutt-Typ bessern kann, hab bei meinem Anbieter keine eigene IPv4, wodurch
mein Nutt-Typ echt immer, also, das erste, was du dir merken musst in dem Fall, es gibt
keinen Nutt-Typ, das ist eine reine, ich weiß, was du meinst, das ist eine reine Erfindung
von Konsolenherstellern, diesen Begriff gibt es nicht, dementsprechend weiß man auch nicht,
was es genau heißen soll, was damit wahrscheinlich gemeint ist, ist, dass man von außen nicht
direkt ne Anfrage an deine Xbox oder Playstation schicken kann, das sollte aber eigentlich
überhaupt nicht notwendig sein, das heißt, nennen wir es mal schlechter Nutt-Typ ist
jetzt erstmal nichts schlechtes, dadurch wird deine Verbindung nicht irgendwie langsamer
oder so, es könnte höchstens sein, wenn es Spiele gibt, die irgendwie peer to peer hosten
ohne Vermittlungs-Server, warum es sowas im Jahr 2020 immer noch gibt, ist mir übrigens
absolutes Rätsel, ja, ich mein, wenn ich mir einen 16-Core-Cloud-Server mieten kann,
um ein bisschen Vermittlung zu machen zwischen den Sessions, dann kann es jeder Indie-Developer
auch, der 2,50 Euro mit seinem Spiel verdient, Blizzard kann das übrigens auch, auch wenn
es eine kleine Indie-Company ist, aber selbst Blizzard kriegt das hin und dementsprechend
ist das eigentlich egal, was, er ist down, er ernsthaft, wow, wie habt ihr das gemacht,
wie habt ihr das gemacht, Deathgrab, was hast du gemacht, hast du Dings hier, Apache, Dings,
Apache Website Benchmark gemacht oder was hast du gemacht, ah, verstehe, nice, ja,
excellent, da sieht man ja mal, wie gut Cloudflare das, was ist denn eine HTTP Amplification,
DNS Amplification, kenne ich, aber was ist denn eine HTTP Amplification, ganz viele Requests,
ja gut, das, aber wahrscheinlich von unterschiedlichen IPs, sodass Cloudflare das nicht checkt,
du willst wahrscheinlich nicht alles von deiner IP aus machen, oder,
nee, ich finde das gut, ich finde, ich finde das, ich finde, ich finde das gut, da sieht
man nämlich, dass das funktioniert, was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde, konntest
du das alles von deiner IP daheim machen, aber botnet, ok, weil ich wollte gerade sagen,
also in ernsthaft jetzt, weil eigentlich sollte Cloudflare das checken, wenn das alles von
einer IP kommt, aber ich frage mich mal, ich frage mich jetzt, ob, ob die das mitkriegen
jetzt mit der Zeit, ob die das dann sperren mit der Zeit, oder, können die nicht filtern,
ok, was, was, ach komm mal hier, a timeout occurred, top, Cloudflare, was sagen die dazu,
sehr gut, das kenne ich, also im Prinzip ist es nichts weiteres, wie ganz viele Computer,
die reguläre, reguläre Anfragen stellen, oder was, natürlich will ich dich nicht dazu
jetzt aufrufen, also keine botnet benutzen Leute, böse, also Anzeige ist raus, so, im
Prinzip, wisst ihr was das witzige ist, dass das, ich meine es ist zwar mehr, aber so weit
weg von dem, was ich mit dem Proxy auf dem Server mache, ist das ja auch gar nicht, oh
ist er, ey ist er, ey ist er komplett abgeschissen jetzt, ich glaube der Container ist komplett
abgeschissen, ne mach nix, mach nix, ist doch ok, oh vielleicht sollte ich meinen richtigen
Ordner, oh Mist, kompa, ja, musst du es richtig machen, so jetzt läuft er wieder, hat er aber
irgendwie hat Ctop jetzt nicht gecheckt, dass er wieder läuft, ah jetzt, ok, nice, ja das
kann auch Youtube auch passieren, aber ganz ehrlich, da kannst du nicht wirklich großartig
was gegen machen, wenn es da jemand so drauf anlegt, was willst du großartig machen, es
sind ja im Prinzip reguläre, reguläre Requests, ja, das einzige was man machen könnte ist,
dass ich beispielsweise nur IPs aus Deutschland erlaube, so regionale Dinger, weil ich gehe
mal davon aus, das Spotnet ist sonst wo verteilt, aber das ist gut, dafür testen wir die ganze
Sache, du kannst doch Cloudflare die Seite Static Cache lassen, ja aber das bringt ja
nix, mach ich ja, mach ich ja, aber das ändert ja nix, dass die weiterhin Backend Calls macht,
aktiviere mal den Cloudflare in den Tag Modus, ah, das ist gut zu wissen, ist gut zu wissen,
ich kann jetzt Cloudflare nicht aktivieren, da müsste ich mich auf der anderen Seite einloggen,
das könnte ich machen, aber klingt auf jeden Fall, es ist gut, dass wir es ausprobiert
haben, weil ungefähr so stelle ich mir das erstmal vor, wenn die Leute über Youtube
drauf zugreifen, ach stimmt genau, ja das habe ich sogar gesehen, das habe ich sogar
schon mal ausprobiert, genau da landest du immer im Capture drin, kann man, vielleicht
kennst du dich ja aus, ich hab das noch nicht großartig verwendet weiter, gibt es in Cloudflare
so einen Modus, wo man sagen kann, ey ab so und so viele Requests, geh automatisch mit
irgendwelche Seitenregeln oder so, ab so und so viele Requests pro Sekunde, geh automatisch
in den Attack Modus, wie kommt man an ein Botnetz dran, das will ich jetzt nicht diskutieren
hier, weil im Zweifelsfall ist es in Deutschland in irgendeiner Art und Weise illegal, deswegen
ich weiß davon nichts, ah Deathgrab, also es könnte sein, es könnte sein, dass nach
einer Viertelstunde die das automatisch eingeschaltet hätten, ja ja interessant, kannst du da noch
den Ryzen dazu nehmen, welchen Ryzen, sind doch alle drinnen, sind doch alle da, benutzt
du privat auch Cloudflare, ja ich benutze Cloudflare für, aber nur für ein DNS bei
mir, für mich privat, aber jetzt so als richtig echtes Projekt habe ich da so bei mir persönlich
nur den Preischamp drinnen, hä, das hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun, das verstehe
ich nicht, Systemd-Unit, T-Max, das hä, äh ach so, das sind die, die gibt es so nur
mit x, guck mal, die gibt es doch nur mit x oder, die 5900x und 5900x ist das gleiche,
ne ne, genau Deathgrab, sowas ist richtig, exellent, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
exellent, kannst du mal DNS und Cloudflare, wir haben sogar einen Stream gemacht, wo ich
DNS mit Cloudflare eingerichtet habe, das ist easy, also Cloudflare ist, Cloudflare
sieht übelst verwirrend aus, aber die Basics-Sachen, und wir wissen ja, man muss erstmal die Basics
machen und dann ist das richtig, ähm, Cloudflare kostet doch überhaupt nichts, aber wenn
man, wenn man nur bei den Basics-Sachen bleibt, ist Cloudflare tatsächlich, du kannst in
den DNS-Settings 99% das einstellen, was du brauchst, oh da ist ganz schön am vibrieren
hier, Gatschi-Buzz, Max meinst doch, wenn der Bitkontroppt investierst du, ich weiß
nicht, keine Ahnung, äh, da hast du recht Deathgrab, ja, ich hab eigentlich überall
die Domain, aber, muss noch mal gucken, gut, das würde ich ja hier in den Netzwerk-Dingern
sehen, ob da da irgendwie, ich hab auch gesagt, dass Cloudflare soll das alles cashen und
ausliefern, gut, das ist alles Google, das ist alles, also ich hab eigentlich da keine
eigenen Sachen drin, ich hab, ähm, Google Zeug und FFZ-Bilder, aber die gehen ja auch
hin, ich hoffe da steht wirklich nirgendswo was drinnen, ich hab mir das jetzt so genau
angeguckt, ich mein, ich könnte einfach alle IPs, im Zweifelsfall sperr ich alle IPs aus,
die nicht deutsch an Österreich und Schweiz sind, das Archiv ist down, oh Sebaro, was
ist da los, der Cute-Mod macht wieder Dinger, ja, ja, das glaub ich, ich geh eher davon
aus, dass da Sebaro grad was bastelt, der Sebaro ist grad wahrscheinlich am Uploaden
oder was, keine Ahnung, also, ihr könnt's in dem Sebaro, Ed Sebaro in Discord posten,
der guckt sich das an, den Server betreibe ich nämlich nicht selbst vor und das Archiv,
das ist nicht meiner, Sebaro ist hinter als Hochland, ja, kann durchaus sein, ich bin
echt mal gespannt, wenn ich das auf YouTube hau, wie viel Last das dann so verursacht,
ich, wisst ihr was, im Zweifelsfall, Zweifelsfall, Hetzner, er holt mir so ein Hetzner 32 Score,
Bam, Keg-Waite, womit ich da jetzt raus, ah, bei den anderen, warum tauchen die als
erstes auf mit Hetzner, Alter, das sind Drecksäge hier, guckt euch das mal an, das waren paar
100.000 Request, du warst es nicht aber letztens auch schon, oder, wir hatten nämlich letztens
auch ein paar lustige DDoSer, als ich noch ohne Cloudflare einfach im Stream ein bisschen
entwickelt hab und die Sache abgeloadet hab, weil da waren wir auch ein paar lustige Leute,
da bin ich, da war ich dann irgendwann am, am Linux Kernel Connection, Contract Connection
Limit und das Ding hat rumgesprungen, in die Magenta Cloud, ja, Pock, aber so ist das halt
wenn man Sachen Public macht, ja, so, also was haben die hier so zu bieten, zeig mal
her, Server Finder, Server Burst, EX Linie, AX Linie, PX Linie, SX Linie, wo ist das,
Dell, warum haben die nochmal extra Dell, Server Finder, Server Burst, ok, wir gucken
jetzt mal, wenn man noch was Fetteres braucht, was dann Sache ist, warum mach ich immer Hetzner,
weil ich bisher gute Erfahrungen mit Hetzner gemacht hab, weißt du warum Ctop auf meinem
Raspberry Pi Zudo braucht, ja, weil das Ding auf den Docker Demon zugreifen muss und das
Düft darf nur root, du kannst allerdings deine User auch in die Docker Gruppe adden, dann
dürfte es funktionieren, allerdings ist der Router damit mehr oder weniger root, so, zeig
mal her, was haben die sonst noch für fette Teile, EX 42 NVMe, Quad Core, damit fangen
wir erst gar nicht an, kannst du mehrere Backend Instanzen laufen lassen, ja könnte ich, allerdings
müsste ich eine Sache dazu machen, das ist nicht schwierig, aber um mehrere Backend Instanzen
laufen zu lassen, was übrigens gar keine so schlechte Idee ist, dann könnte ich irgendwie
ein bisschen DNS-Loudbalancing machen oder sowas, was wollte ich sagen, ich könnte mehrere
DNS laufen lassen, achso, ja, die Cloudsäufer bei Hetzner haben gar keine Firewall, aber
die normalen haben glaube ich welche, da gibt es preisgünstig welche, ok, zeig mal her,
ich mach das jetzt einfach mal auf und hoffe, dass es keine Pornseite ist, ok, sieht gut
aus, sieht gut aus, ah Mist, jetzt habe ich nicht geguckt, was habe ich gerade erzählt,
jetzt habt ihr mich abgelenkt, ja, das habe ich nur am Rande mitgekriegt mit der Route
Sicherheitslücke, ok, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich erzählen wollte gerade, achso, ja,
das Backend, das Backend kann man mehrfach laufen lassen, was ich dazu machen muss ist
folgendes, also aktuell ist es halt so, ich habe hier eine DB und da liegt eine SQLite
Datenbank rum und da ist alles drin, sagenhafte 12 MB, ja, das ist nicht mein Server, so und
ich kann das Backend nicht mehrfach laufen lassen, wobei, doch kann ich, ich kann das
Backend mehrfach laufen lassen, ähm, weil das Backend würde ich dann starten und mehrfach
an dem MQTT Server einliefern lassen und dann würden beide Backends einfach das gleiche
in die Datenbank schreiben, das ist eigentlich gar nicht doof, ich glaube, das mache ich,
oder aber wenn das nicht geht, dann müsste ich eine Postgres Datenbank nehmen oder irgendwas,
wo man halt, ähm, parallel drauf zugreifen kann, nee, ich muss den MQTT, ich muss schon
in beiden Sachen starten, weil sonst kriegt es ja ein, ein, ein, ein, ein Backend kriegt
da die Datenbankänderung sonst nicht mit, also es würde funktionieren, das würde funktionieren,
vielleicht mache ich das auch, vielleicht mache ich das auch, du hast auch einen VU-Server,
nice, vielleicht mache ich das auch, so, so wenn ich das mache, so einen Hetzner Load
Balancer mal davor, testweise, oder nee, ich mache DNS Load, DNS Load, wobei, geht DNS
Load Balancing mit Cloudflare denn noch, ja klar, müsste, müsste eigentlich funktionieren,
gleicher Eintrag, zwei RPs, ja, ich finde es interessant, ich habe ja noch nie so ein
Public Service Released und auf was man da alles gucken muss, übelst nice, lernt man
echt was bei, den Crawler lasse ich nur einmal laufen, ja, ja, ich mache das so, ich stelle
den Crawler so ein, dass der an beide Frontends einliefert oder ich mache es doch über eine
Postgres, also über eine Postgres wäre eigentlich irgendwie schöner, ok, jetzt wollte ich mal
kurz gucken, was haben die hier noch so Sachen im Angebot gehabt, by the way, was haben wir
von der Auslastung, nix, easy, also das wollte ich, das sollte ich mir jetzt mal angucken,
Deathgrab und warum, weil Hetzner dich irgendwie geblockt hat oder, und da dann alles von einer
RP kam oder, ah ne, du hast geroutet, ich geproxiedet, weshalb, ja, ich würde den MQTT Server rausziehen
oder ich lasse einfach den Street Merchant an zwei MQTT Server liefern, das kann der
wahrscheinlich sogar, ok, also was kostet denn bei denen, zeig mal her, Essentials, ok,
die haben nur zwei Sachen, OVH, bei denen hatte ich auch mal was, ist aber schon bestimmt
zwei Jahre her, wie und das und das, hä, das ist doch genau das gleiche oder, warum
haben die zwei verschiedene Server, äh, zwei verschiedene Seiten, achso, verstehe, Hetzner,
ok, ah, ok, ähm, gucken wir mal, Game Server, Essentials, Essentials Dedicated Server, was
haben die da am Start, ähm, gibt es das auch vielleicht in irgendeinem anderen Land so,
was in der Nähe ist, ach, das sind alles nur vier Kerner, ah, der vier Kerner ist ja
mein Crawler schon ausgelastet, die Digital Ausschnitt ist ziemlich teuer, also mit vier
Kerne komme ich echt nicht hin, sechs Kerne, ne, ich brauche allein schon zwölf Kerne
für den Crawler, echt verscheuert, aber der Crawler braucht am meisten Leitung, es sei
der nur denost, aber, ja, ne, das sind zu wenig Kerne, also ich brauche 16 Kerne oder
zumindest einen, der mindestens acht hat, ach, guck mal hier, siehste das, der geht
teilweise hoch, der geht teilweise hoch auf tausend Prozent, also der, der braucht so
zehn bis zwölf Kerne, aber dafür muss man sagen, Docker, Compose, Logs, der ist mittlerweile
ziemlich, ähm, ziemlich gut, der schlägt kaum noch fehl, seht ihr das, guck mal, der
spricht kaum noch ab, also die Idee mit den zehn Public IPs und da drüber zu crawlen
war eine richtig gute Idee, was witzigerweise ein bisschen ähnlich ist zu dem DDoS eben,
nur halt von weniger, ich verteile ja mein Traffic auch, ich kriege ja kaum noch 500
Treis und sonst was, wo ist Amazon, hallo, es ist Amazon, oh, ich kriege, ich kriege
wieder 503 von Amazon, null, Captcha, okay, es ist doch zu viel für Amazon, die Anfragen,
das Preischamp botnet, egal, was ist das, zeig her, nee, nee, ich mach jetzt keine
Attackmodus an, ich geh jetzt eh gleich off, ja, ich hab Streetmatch auf mehrere IPs ausgelagert,
so was, das, 8 Kerne, okay, da kommen wir schnell, aber das reicht ja dann fürs Frontendet,
also ich brauch eigentlich, ich brauch eigentlich 16 Kerne, klingt jetzt, ganz ehrlich Leute,
ich hätt's euch auch nicht geglaubt, ja, hättet ihr zu jemand gesagt, für so was brauchst
du 16 Kerne, hätt ich's nicht geglaubt, aber bleibt dir nix anderes da übrig, 16 Kerne
wird super teuer, das geht, ich bezahle da glaub 55 Euro oder so, da kann ich mit leben,
wollen wir kurz bei Etzer gucken, was das, so als echter Server kostet, 8 Kerne, nope,
32 Core, beste, guck mal, für 130 Euro im Monat kriegen wir 32 Kerne, so muss das sein,
das ist eigentlich echt billig, ne, was spricht gegen AX41, zu wenig Kerne, Etzer Cloud Pricing,
ich bin aktuell da, aber das sind keine Dedicated CPUs, ne, das ist eine KVM-VM mit 16 Kernen,
aber ganz ehrlich, das flutscht auch so, ja, das ist das natürlich teurer, guckt euch
das hier mal an, null W, ne, aber das ist, aber man muss sagen, also ohne Mist, 32 Kerne
für 130 Euro, das ist gar nicht schlecht, was ist ein Dedicated-VCPU, ja, das klingt
erstmal widersprüchlich, ist es aber nicht, du kriegst dann halt, normalerweise ist es
ja so, dass wenn du, was weiß ich, 30 User auf so einem VM-Sofer hast, dass die sich
die Ressourcen sharen und wenn es ein Dedicated-CPU ist, dann ist es halt nur für dich reserviert,
was du in deiner Virtualisierungssoftware anhaken, aber das machen die bei Etzer ganz gut, also
ich hab da jetzt keine großen Performance-Probleme bisher gehabt, aber ich hab jetzt auch nicht
so was Fettes drauf laufen lassen mit so vielen Leuten, so, also, das ist echt billig,
sondern was haben die sonst noch hier am Start, was hat eben jemand geschickt, ne, der hat
zu klein, zu wenig Kerne, ich brauch, wenn schon, 16 Core, da kann man, ist auch okay,
ist auch okay, ähm, Tobix, ist es ein.NET-Container, die haben ein Bug seit gestern, ja, achso,
weil der offizielle.NET-Container hat einen NuGet-Bug, man muss den Ubuntu-Container nehmen,
dann geht's, ne, da kann ich nichts zu sagen, guck dir die Firewall an von OVH, wo ist denn
das drunter, wo, oder meinst du im Management-Interface, achso, warum hab ich Google eingegeben, lull,
was da, was da war's, achja, das hab ich ja hier auf, was war das, wack, wo ist er, wo
ist er, wusste ich gar nicht, was haben die mit wack zu tun, so, ähm, aha, das heißt,
wenn ich einen Server da hab, brauch ich gar keinen Cloudflare mehr davor, wack, ja, aber,
das was du eben, also 30 Milliarden Requests oder was auch immer du da gerade geschickt
hast, da hätte ja die OVH-Firewall auch nichts wirklich gemacht, das waren ja legit, legit
Requests quasi, wie viele Requests waren es nicht, was weiß ich, paar hunderttausend,
so, ähm, und das ist überall dabei und kostet nix oder was, ok, dann gucken wir mal, dann
gucken wir mal, was der Kram kostet bei denen, ein Core, acht Core, zu wenig, Leute, sechzehn
Core, ok, sag mal so, ich könnte den Crawler auch auf zwei splitten, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, was, was wollen die eigentlich hier von mir, w- warum ist ein Virtual-Server Bear
das hatte ich gerade auf ne
ja muss man was überlegen
zelt mal her aha prozessor jawoll ok ok
fangen wir mal 12 an aber 12 wird es wahrscheinlich nicht geben so also 130 für 16 kerner gut
oh da wirds teuer leute kann man irgendwo donaten nee das war erstmal nicht da wirds teuer
24 scores easy jawoll
schön alper wenn es dir gefallen hat
ja nice das ist mir dann doch ein bisschen teuer
in eschern mach ich privat nichts da muss auf der arbeit schon genug rum eschern mich mit
rum eschern das steht aber auch zweimal oder sind zweimal 28 course das ist dann vielleicht
doch ein bisschen zu hart das ist 705 das ist verfügbar in sieben rechten zentrum liefungen
bis zu 120 sekunden her da kommt natürlich darauf an dass ich die das dass ich die 705
euer früher verbraucht habe das ist raus stimmt überhaupt nicht
gibt es hier war da mal ich ich schalte jetzt mal hier auf 12 kerne ich mein oder auf acht
weil ich mein zweimal ist ja auch ok guck mal das sind zweimal 24 nee es sind zweimal
davon die cpu sind insgesamt 24 oder moment jaja ok ok ok das sind zweimal 12 ist halt
ordentlich ich meine da sieht man mal wie warum ist das sag mal warum sind die bei
hetzer so billig ich meine die hatten die du jetzt bei hetzer haben 32 korb für 130
euro ich weiß schon gar nicht wo es hin ist hier guck mal 32 kerne für 130 euro bei der
serverbörse habe ich heute noch nicht geguckt da wir können auch mal gucken da typ dankeschön
ja naja gut da ist ja wenn nichts da vor ist und mal anzahl what moment kann man da nicht
nach cpu anzahlen wie filtern ich hatte mal ein ich hatte mal eine ganze weile ein von
der serverbörse aber nur weil er viele festplatten drinne hatte ok volle pulle bäm da gibts
ein 32 korb den kann ich mir doch auch so direkt kaufen 12 kerne 32 kerne den kann ich mir doch
auch so kaufen null was ist der unterschied zwischen dem ok das ist ja 32 kerne was haben
die dann sonst noch am start neu 18 grad das ist intel stellts ok guck mal bei intel kriegst
ein 18 korb für den gleichen preis wie bei amd 32 korb nice so dann haben wir noch mehr
zu bieten dann haben wir noch sx 320 easy jetzt jetzt ah die haben die haben mehr mehr ram
ne hä moment warum kostet der warum kostet der so viel obwohl es nur 8 kerne sind was
ist was ist denn an denen jetzt ach storage server enterprise ok das ist das ist storage
das ist storage was der ax hat keine festplatten ah gegen auf preis ok aber der hier hat details
konfigurieren ok zeig mal was kostet mit deutschler wird schon teurer verstehe preis
gem kann auch in finnland laufen guck mal da wirds auch ganz schnell teuer aber leute
nice dass wir es mal getestet haben wirklich sehr gut jetzt weiß ich schon mal auf was
ich gucken muss könnte man einen ovh server nicht als proxy verwenden für die firewall
doch aber ich habe ja schon cloudflare davor also einfach nur eine andere infrastruktur
wo es dann durch geht machts jetzt hätte da jetzt nichts gemacht also traffic kommt
da hinten auf dem server an und das ist legit zugriffe die macht den server halt down beziehungsweise
die macht ovh filter das weg warum filtert ovh das weg und aber wie kann wie kann ovh
denn quasi valid requests wegfiltern woher wollen die das wissen weil der cache nix an
meinem backend macht ok ja gut das ich mein dafür wirds ja auch ein kleiner wollen muss
mal gucken was war das hier die waren billiger essential geht das hier auch da durch ne das
ist zu teuer ok wenn ich da was kleines also im prinzip wahrscheinlich rein als wir routen
das durch würde ich mal so dual core nehmen oder sowas vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt
jetzt nicht unbedingt den ein core aber vielleicht vielleicht eher den da wenn da viel durch
geht ist vielleicht ein core nicht so das beste oder oder man nimmt ich will dich 20
euro ich will dich extra noch mal 20 euro firewall da vorstellen weil das ist die einzigen
mit gigabit anbindung und dann engine x nö ich mein man könnte man könnte auch proxien
ja könnte man auch machen
ich mache mir mal Gedanken drüber
was geht heute ich gehe jetzt auf ins bett
stellen sie mal dankeschön für den primes ab
ja vielleicht streben ich morgen wieder eine runde ich muss aber den preischamp noch fertig
machen ich wie gesagt ich baue ja da in nur noch eine
geschichte ein ich werde gucken dass die paar box fixe hier zum beispiel mit der suche dass
das hier mit den mit den krafts funktioniert zum filtern und ja ich habe ich habe noch
ein paar kleine sachen aufgeschrieben also hier das notification fenster dass man das
besser bedienen kann und dann gucke ich mal dass man das da noch noch noch ein bisschen
den aus sicherer macht alles um acht habe ich noch nie gestreamt ach du mein sonntag
sonntag streben schon zehn um acht
boomer zeiten ob um zehn sonntags was ist an zehn um sonntag boomer alter die anwendung
vor und der crawler ist noch gs aber der crawler ist nicht von mir sonst hätte ich den auch
nicht in not gebastelt bitte keine pns ja jetzt hast du das da hast du dich jetzt selber
reingeritten die leute werden dich nach wie vor fragen
sagen wir ist das impressum highlighten das andere nicht sieht das sieht das weiße aus
als das ne oder dass mein monitor da grad ein bisschen rumspielen oder mein auge oder
mein auge ist kaputt
boomer augen ja
also ok leute ich gehe jetzt ins bett ich muss morgen wieder arbeiten wir sehen uns
machts gut vielleicht bis morgen bis denn machts gut